foreign
and
in this video we will be creating a
clone of Facebook but before we begin if
you haven't subscribed to our Channel
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and press the Bell icon so you
will never miss any update from Simply
learn
so without further Ado let's begin and
see what's in it for you so let me show
you
how a app will look like
here we are going to create a Facebook
clone with react.js
but before we jump to the coding part
let me show you how our Facebook login
page looks like
so we're gonna go to the Google
and this is how our Facebook loan will
look like
you can also log in from here
in this here
you have to write your email address
like my email address is
and I'll write the password and password
I can write
and then
here I'll click on the login
it will ask me to say and never and this
is how I will login page main page will
look like
here you can add your status
this is your login your search bar
and here you can also add the status
and this is how you can upload a picture
so
we can easily create this clone
follow me throughout this video and you
will learn how to create a Facebook loan
so without further Ado let's create this
Facebook loan from scratch with a fun
manner
but first let me tell you what react.js
is
so what is react.js react is a
JavaScript library that is used to build
mobile and web applications fast and
interactive it is an open source
reusable component based front-end
library of JavaScript react is a
combination of HTML and JavaScript
it provides a reverse and opinionated
way to build modern applications
so now
let's create this folder
back to our Visual Studio code
for this
you have to install node.js in your
laptop
and
react yes you can also
get our videos
just type how to install node.js and
react.js on your system on our Channel
you'll get plenty of videos of this
so we'll go and create
new folder
let's
minimize this
say this
will open our terminal
press Ctrl backtick
or you can also
go here
and press terminal and new terminal okay
now
you have opened our terminal
here
you have to create a react project
so for that
we'll write a command
let's just delete this
everything's look fine
in this video I will also show you how
to create a shortcut and you can use
which are used by the Developers
Now to create an empty react project the
command is
npx
create
react
app
and then
the folder name
so I'm gonna write the folder name as
Facebook
clone
doubly because I have already created
Facebook clone with single e so I'm
gonna write clone press enter
this will take couple of minutes to
install all the modules so let's wait a
for few seconds till it's finished
let's wait a couple of minutes more
so let's
cut this
okay maybe I have to log this out
as you can see it's installing all the
modules of the app
like the ad react Dom VR script
moving forward we will also install the
ACT modules like
in the yard
okay right let's talk about that further
in this tutorial
now we'll go into the
clone
now we'll write in VM start
and this will open up the ad project
so the first step is done here now
coming back to our code
let's open this folder
my folder is inside this
C drive so I'm going to go to this
there
users
and this is my folder as you can see
I've already created this little clue
so
this is how
you are folder will look like
inside the source folder you will have
this
app.js you don't need this logo
so we're gonna delete this
we'll show some error let's see
coming back to index.js
let me do very few things here also
but before that let me add one file here
a couple of seconds
you can add that further in this
tutorial also
hello
we will remove this logo from here
instead of this it will import
react
well you don't need this header also
here and right
hello
from
simply done
let's open Terminal
inside this Facebook loan you have
already in this code so you won't have
to tell you a CD let's zoom in for you
guys
this is fine
so it's showing hello from singular
add to a cone now let's not waste any
time and build our Facebook load up
now let's create a folder here
as login page
inside this folder we're going to create
two files login page node.js
and
login
page dot CSS
inside this GS file we're going to write
all our code and inside this we are
going to do all our saving part
to coming back to our locking page we're
going to first import react
after input is react
we need to import the CSS file for this
login
okay
okay
fine
now
we'll create a function
of your login page
inside this function
in the create one
fifth class
of login
inside this we're going to create
another class
name let's name it Facebook
create another class of Facebook text
so these are the keywords that we are
going to use in our CSS file
so let's hit add Facebook
and here will export r
s login page
let's save this
code let's delete this part
and then we'll write
the login page
let's call it Insider approaches
okay
let's find the problem here
okay problem is here
do not install or import our file like
this
let's now save it and you can see
it's free
coming back to our app dot CSS
here we go this so we're gonna delete
and save this way let's from this part
okay
now
going back to our index.js
now we cannot see the Facebook
written in yours um
so let's just see what's fish okay
so we need to okay come on
now let's save this as you can see the
Facebook is written
now let's move forward with our code
let's create this one
let's create another
class name
let me say this we're gonna write before
that let me log into my Facebook account
to see
what are we going to create
as you can see we are going to create
this
let's copy this text
let me paste it here
and as you can see it's break after
share
you're fine fine
coming back to a code let's see
Facebook with after one
that's
move forward
after this
let's create a
class name of container
so we're going to create this argument
but this is finished I'm gonna just
create this one you can study this color
and everything you never see this is
a code
let's name this as you know how to
container
class
last night
okay we're gonna add
two login inputs one for this email and
password
so let's
fill it up for a second word
thank you thank you
email
so react is a very intelligent language
there we are going to write emails with
just automatically knows that where you
have to write the email ID and then set
this password and I'll give it a type
password
it automatically knows it's a password
type
so let's
hold here in this placeholder
let's click on this
this email address or password
placeholder is nothing but what's being
in the right hand side is it can't be
fixed
so it's for the user
only do it
he
press or
we will explain
this after this let's create
games let's create a video
another
guide
save this
it's time to save this and sleep
good looking good
yes
it's coming back to our code
we are going to style this part it'll
look like this only
so just wait a couple of more minutes to
see the amazing love intention
to creating this facing this we are
going to create a button
but actually it's nice
okay
let's just
delete button
is created or not it's created
okay now
coming back to a gold
see it for your password I think
it's creating Enterprise
oh God
okay and inside this I'm going to give
it back
forget
them
foreign
C8
is just
let's take this
button
we need a lot of experience
[Music]
as you guys
because me as
in this world each other
so that's disabled this poverty
and then save this button right what's
inside this create new account
create account
so now you know like this create a page
or a celebrating plan on business
go to this button
that's pretty good space
also
let's create another class name
I'm going to create another tab
after 38.
please
create
foreign
save this and see what's output so
everything looks fine like this only now
the amazing part is the styling part now
we're going to style this part we'll
create it like this isn't it amazing
let's go to our code and inside our
login.css
let's come here
this file is here and
but it's
the first
okay
[Music]
six would be fine
then this part will imply on a full page
so this is a binder
save it
inside this box size
foreign
in this login
reflects all this for this
would be
and in terms
fix it up for that
for Content should be space between him
so isn't it looking fine
let's move forward
you'll get to see everything like this
login page but we are going to create a
full fridge
so just be with me
okay
and yes
project
now
some years were fixed
it's full countries
let's say this let's give the pattern
also
on Save
me let's give it a three now
color
[Music]
to
yes
it will be
let's say this okay
yes
and say it should be six
650 rules
let's give it
listening
it's looking like let's
see
what's 780
created
it's just more forward
we win
it's right right
for this
five
okay
let's say this this
somebody is the size
to move forward
let's see you
I'm starting so
I'm not
those continues
so let's create a login
multi-sensitives
let's see between this we're going to do
so let's give it a reporter of
hate it
bullets
we
will be able to quite a little
spoky friends coming back to him
let's give it
it's too late
[Music]
for me to face
it's where it is
0.7
circus
destruction
we will continue
let's see the issue with the container
Excel
and he shows here
amazing
it's include the size
is like this
things
instructor 2016
what radius
a word
it's
under there
was an email
here
let's give it a bit unrealism
the width will be given inside this
container
so we can jump 100
20 pixels
[Music]
pretty much
thank you
I'm just succeeding
um
yes
what do you think
it's for me but we should
fluency against this
crazy
yeah
just delete this one
and let's
stick to our parents
so
you would imagine now three pixels
same thing should be
memory box now
foreign
also
let's copy this component
paste it here
because what we'll be saying
so
password
and smoke on this please hurry up
input
please hold them
for example this is
let me check that
it's much more
so let's give it completely that's
something fine
yes
now let's work on the button part
with that let's give it a display of
flex
Direction
will be
something like this so it's slow
and width would be
good again
so we will copy this
then
let's squeeze it and save this button
again
and now let's see
isn't it looking amazing
let's go recorder
no
exciting
um
if it is
great
if I could end
up
save it it's coming in the center
General
so I'm going to decide
actually
that's
this I'm standing
and this would be five frame
should be
okay let's give it away
if you get text and decorations no
it's looking
more Lego
Court let's see here
okay everything's looks great
and let's have to see the pattern
for now
can you do
it's very nice you know
you're happy to leave this after few
minutes because
this he was already we are going to
delete this part to login
but let's see this
this can be disabled is like a
literature
a little Slim
just jokes a bit
this is not good
foreign
but then we have to increase
they just says
alignment would have been entered again
display always flicks and I've told you
on this and I will be ready
here at first okay
yeah
this
but it would be the same
it's
God damn it
we do
if there's
me
and this looks pretty
straight at this button
it's looking right now
I'm creating this
let's work on this button part
nership
but
it's
Jesus part
of those images in the first
let's just play
fix
I'm just fingered it
Center
foreign
[Music]
yes
yes
slowly coming like a button
so let's first give it a trading list
it would be 15 pixels and
confidence
in this book
see
this one
foreign
it's difficult
let's move forward
and here you'll give a bit of
off flakes
bold
and what will reach this
25
margin
we have to left of 20 minutes
so save and see the magic
isn't it looking amazing right yeah
so let's
move forward
let's create a page for this let's field
honestly so
we can do
and every color would be
scared
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
size
font size would be
one
after that let's give it a painting of
left
ten percent
[Music]
let's move forward
with sleeping five minutes
okay
exactly
sweet
save this
shouldn't be here
that you've come up to listen but let's
not give it a doctor it's really like
this so let's
continue
sounds good
sort of so let's do
add this
which comes after this one
yeah looks good now let's change the
color
it's not but it's just
and let's save this
reading the color
so
it's not
like this
it's
infected
extrication is
changes
the color
White
okay
let's hit this button always first
that's now save this
so we are done our
page
excuse me
it's looking amazing it's like this only
changes are needed
but let's not dig deep into this you can
also
have a few things
which looks fine to me so
[Music]
let's Now work on our
domain page open this
let's create a folder
and
Maybe
it's good let's Now work on the header
button
which is let me log in first
Min B
so my Facebook is logged in first thing
we're going to create is this part this
header button is going to search by whom
then these all buttons and these things
coming back to our code
let's open it up into the dot so let's
create the files for this
here
area dot Js and then the new file header
area dot CSS first item
let's cut this part
the first thing we're going to do is
import react
after that we're going to import
the CSS file so for that
area dot CSS
architect will create a function of
federal block
inside this we will return
welcome
let's just save this file
and just wait a couple of seconds
okay
and then
to our
this value
let's just see the full screen inside
this login button
so when I will click on this login
it will redirect us to the homepage for
this Facebook
so we're going to declare the link
to
header
area
and this will drive the object
let's just save the start
we have to declare the react router but
for that let's open our terminal
inside this terminal we are going to
install the ACT router down so for that
we are going to write this command
npn install
iPhone iPhone save react router down at
5.3.0
so let's install these files
it will take a minute so
in the meanwhile
I'm going to add one file here
so let's import that also
it's done
so let's let's just close this and close
the
import link
from
area
let's save this
it is showing a command V accessed
so let's see the issue fine difference
forward
save this coming back to the code
let's see
it's for this
moving back to app.js
here
we are going to bring forward
Universal reaction
we will do the shout
and switch my third here
this folder
which is
right now I'm going to see login and
let's import
header area from headed area
let's just delete this file and then set
this we're going to hit switch
and switch will route our plots from one
page to another
pretty well tell you why we are doing
this you just give me a couple of
minutes
start
when it's true
we're going to redirect our company
login
let's just close this here
let's just copy this
movie
and his we are going to write
header
area
and this is not we are going to need
here
and here also we are going to teacher
so this function we have result here
where we have it in this switch end out
so because of this function the page
will redirect from
it's just
start this
this is doing what it is it will
redirect our login page to the header
page
that's why we have written here route
from log into Data button on the main
page
let's wait a couple of seconds to see
the results
okay
it's showing me the better
let's just resolve this error
login page
link
[Music]
okay
okay
let's just save this again and let's see
what it does now
get successful you compile
let's go back to the login page
let's not showing you the login page
right now
let's find out the issue here
but it's not redirecting me
okay
let's see
now I have added one file here
service.worker.js
you can find all these files in the
description box
I'm going to give a drive link where you
will find all this code for free
so I was waited one image folder in
which I have added few images
like this and I'm going to use in this
so let's close this this
part
and this is done
is it also done so let's
work on this
so I've done few changes in this file
also you can see
that I will put in this service worker
from service worker and then browse it
out now let's see our output
let's see the link is working or not
into our login page here I'm going to
write an email address
the password
and just okay it's showing wrong so
let's just
buy it soon welcome to simpler
isn't it awesome let's go back to our
it's been interesting here in the middle
okay yeah
let's just save this
and I'm going back to login
I should
and check on the login it will show us
welcome to simpler
so let's go back to our header India
part let's just delete this
and sign this div let's get a class name
um
homepage
to that let's create another
yes
inside this header
okay everything's look good
inside this header we are going to write
another class
of meal first hitter
and if
logo
and then
add up yoga
so inside there is something like image
source of the image is
slash logo dot PNG
let's just see
let's just see the editings okay
let's see let's see this and see nice
because
I'm coming back to a code let's make few
changes of styling inside this will
leave
all the this logo
okay
PNG
logo
time
the flick
the directions would be fine
okay
let's give it a betting also from now
and then
okay
let's save this and as you will see it's
coming
right like this isn't it amazing
I'm loving it
let's go back to our code again
and now this logo
we're going to add one
so far it's like this socialism back to
our code
this part is done
okay
so let's work on our
okay but before this we have to do it
with another file
let's
installing the
icons nbm install reactor and I can save
so it will install all the icons for us
like fa users have register and we are
going to use that no worries if you
don't do that I'm going to cover up in
this video
so coming back to our code
it's just
C
okay
I'm just thrown a little
yeah perfect
you know
in this spot is done
after this logo part we'll create
another tab
us would be search is fine
search
and save this we're going to add AI
outline
search
I'm going to import these
here also
we'll do that you know choose it let's
just first conclude this part foreign
yes well you have it imported this from
the applicant so let's import
root
icons slash
yeah but it comes under delivery
let's say this and now
this logo is coming
nice
lips
going forward
yeah we can know all the changes in the
CSS file you want to worry
coming back
actually let's move forward and let's
inside this we need to import
in the place from the press and
consultant search capital
and the type was
research
Spark
swim project
this hand side
we'll be fine
let's now move forward with these icons
okay
let's
and let's create another div class
let's see this metal
inside this middle header
I'm going to create one Dev class
becomes
yeah
that's good
[Music]
after this we are going to write a i
said
um
and Save
2.3 or too much let's try to continue
to color for this would be
let's see
value will be
okay
although you will be triggered and then
this one would be active so I'll tell
you what is it
eight level seven
let's close this
38
few classes like this
is
fine
moving forward
let's just delete these
I'll tell you why I have written it
inside the post icon
so
why I have written this in the first
part is
because we need this as a blue and these
are all follows so that's why I have
written here the color wrist blue I have
in this color blue
so
let's stream these names again
so it's the second one
okay
G
flat
and then the same font size will be
there
for the energy
empty
and then
and d e command
video
the fourth one units I forgot his name
users
users
and us to one is smart
okay
no remember
okay then search
select wallet
go every
let's see the results
option for these files
Village
let's forget this
and let's improve these parts
so the AI ones will come here and we
need to declare one another one
those lips
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
it was like Yay
[Music]
was it
they're not fitting it I don't know why
Arrow said
it will exist
let's first complete the code then let's
add these things
this was completely start
and then we'll move forward with the
click on four minutes
let's create one another div
its name
third
header
inside this header I'm going to create
one
from there of class name pulses and
let's puzzles
that's what I said this f e
Plus
on
install
this is very easy I guess
right
are you guys
let's just copy this component and let's
use this
okay
let's make this names here
uh to add one picture of mine also here
is for
it's India
messenger okay
and the
in this part fourth one is my picture so
let's just
cut this part
and instead of this image
Supply management key again and save the
image folder
images it's something from images
so inside these images that's one
G okay
let's save this
okay fine
go into progress also
maybe this looks fine but we need to
import all the modules here AI
well it okay
so it's important let's write all these
fields here and embodies
okay
to report the MD and the efforts of
first we have entrance board
F components
f a
okay come on
users plugin
f a
the circles f a
Facebook
and
see
on messenger okay fine everything's look
good
okay once this is coming
AI
yeah I outline
looks like me
you're going to throw
icons
Americans slash everything
let's do this and save it
okay it's not okay
save it let's find now
let's see the output here
it's showing that the md1
on demand
okay
enough
we have an opportunities component of MD
and it was
only one
definitely
okay
from
New York
icons slash family let's save it and see
the outputation
fetching the data oh it's fetching fine
so the Facebook logo that you have seen
here
this is that search box home button
which I have told you that it will do
blue flag YouTube friends and these are
all the buttons in this image you need
to
throughout this image into circle like
this
so what we're going to do is we are
going to add
pelvis TP
let's alter this
said the style
and let's give it a
height of
40 pixels brackets
now let's save and see
is not
see here or something
yeah
nice
oh god let's see why it's taking so much
of time
anything for localhost
looks fine to me
it's looking good right now
foreign
like this
okay coming back to our code
yes we are done with our header area.js
page moving forward to the sliding of
this let's let's write it
first thing we are going to do is this
HTML page inside this HTML page let's
give it the phone size
of 60 percent
and the box says it is Project Box
moving ahead we will write in right so
it should come under one and only
zero so let's save and see
okay
fine
yeah coming back
let's start the style is used to
access everything that comes under this
value everything
so here let me check margin
in zero percent
now let's work on the body part and set
the body again we're going to
divide the same 1.6
them
with the cup
after that the background color
should be
right but it's 0 2
F5
okay
see ya right let's
margin
right
insert this notion right
zero after that let's
work on this homepage
maybe indicated
this place should be good yeah
let's look on the header button
inside this header we're going to
declare a few things like this
relationship reflects
and justify content always Facebook to
me or not always between we use space
even you lose often
come back now
these items
into the center
and like this only will add the
background color
right
after that the position is
sticky so we can't move these things
again
from Top
it should be zero
yes
100 percent
and then the fight
that's right for now
and water would be
fine
that should be black
and then the margin
access
let's save it and see
these three coming up
in the left
okay cool
move forward okay let's
okay let's just
to see what's the gym we're going to do
so
this is
some dog
this is not repeating myth
5186
in this big box after this let's work on
the first letter
first yeah
in display
checks focusing
yeah
so let's work on into the search button
now the book has come late
search button
inside this let's review it reflection
straight
windows
signing in a little bit of this
I'm done
yeah
but then it would be
to save
it's a good sleep
yeah right now it's having liquid
another next thing we are going to
remove body base
yes okay
I just 2.8
again the battery would be
no
foreign
seven pixels
okay this is what we are getting a box
now
I'm going to give it
one only
created
it's coming fine okay
so this is coming great
it's no search for anything
research
okay
let's work on this part now
let's
work on this input
thank you please
kind of search
we have to declare here before then okay
then we can
add things
right
we are going to write like
thank you
healthy
searches good
after the pending we're going to give it
a margin
okay
let's get too much and like but
it makes sense
search
let's align these items
to Sender
and the Box saving
Order Box
playing with
50 pixels
diagram
color
brown color
okay
let's
input
okay yes
to call this one
size
save it
okay let's see
looking looks great but it's
yeah let me save this
let's see this
so it's coming
like this eight
the surface is coming to frame
yeah which looks nice let's work on the
middle and right this part to that you
have to go here
to uh let's uh these I have
copied these instructions
so please write these I'll draw some
like I have declare the middle header
inside that I have displayed
should be Flex with these because it
should come like this smoothly and the
alignments in the center which I am
giving one person these icons and all
like this
okay now let's just save this and as you
can see it's coming like this
so let's add
a few things in this finally
for the loop
the thing should be
a d or like 20 would be you would find
it
it's right 15
yeah 15 is much better
image should further with 50 or like
okay
let's see what it says
okay suppose in this image
so it's testing
oops
someone to save this
much great
okay let's get rid of heading it's done
more data
okay I think it's fine
yes
if we could have
a little bit translator
foreign
this looks exactly like this right
now we are going to add few things in
this main page for that
we're going to create a folder here
let's name this uh inside this Source
only as
main area
okay I have already created
inside this main area
two files
yeah let's take this
let's clone your folder
in India inside this folder
two files main area.js for our
JavaScript code
and for the CSS
CSS
first we are going to open our
um
let's import these files here also
it's important
we will need
foreign
[Music]
they let you know
it's looking fine
all right let's see what we can do and
changes
to uh
it's right here as
important
react first react after that
will import this CSS file
important
CSS
after this let's
create a function
of the main area
focused
return
class
[Music]
I'm going to create one right left
right middle and the left
so we'll start working on the right but
before that
let's see what's tissue again
it's the function only
okay
let's say in the poly Port as mainly
there was no
problems okay
let's see okay let's now solve this
issue
uh and imported this file
it's done I'm also imported this mainly
the appearance I just said about
search results okay
we forgot to explode
a file explore default and the file name
is let's save it and boom it's showing
me that the right path
now coming back to a code we have so
many things to be done inside this file
let's not waste any time and work on
this
the first thing we're going to work on
is the right
so let's just make our folder here so we
can easily feed the right type
let's just close this part
or better player empty
let's work on this
let's create a Dev class
name would be a passage there will be
three sides here
after this let's create another draft
they've asked me
and the last name would be profile
okay it's not doing anything before that
look at this screen
and goes into this keyboard
image
in the source of the image I have
imported these images
universe
you always have to
start this afternoon just do it now
and style it
is here to feed
or 60 pixels
360 pixels
and per day
of one
okay
foreign
and then
I'm going to create another class
and then let's grow
save this
I'm gonna add these videos icon
so we're gonna need this fa users
against
color
question
you
and the phone says
be
Jordan
inside this stuff
friends
let's just save it and show that I have
not imported these icons but I'll do it
later let me show you what I'm going to
do I have declared when this picture of
my need and my name again I'm going to
write this friends groups marketing and
all and then this
from the beginning two or four maybe
like okay
come back to our code
it's just forward let's just copy this
component
let's just copy this and paste it here
I feel nice
okay
so after the user friend I'm going to
add
Fe
AR
awesome
black yeah
because of the green
and one says
after that let's
enter
and let's give you the color blue
but here I'm gonna write
[Music]
I think
information
Center
let's save it
after that
I'm going to infuse the messenger
and
I would be clean for this
after this Kuwait I'm going to write
messenger
Messengers
kids
save it
soon again let's face it
no
because it would be green only let's see
if I can see
let's see it
and let's give it some break
to this let's create another Tiff
feelings
profiles then let's move forward
in here
after the profiles I'm going to add one
image source
yeah images
inside these images
logo
Style
to understand
eight
45 pixels
P1
00
okay
developer
let's
now copy this component
yeah
let's copy this component
heading
a few times
three so
I said one more for the C motion
okay
everything will look great because it
follow me it's fine forward let's steal
the knees here then you just
four
so here I'm going to write
the mean stack
attack
JavaScript
and then again we have to look defined
and let's add
one more
yes for just see more and the promise
you know like pros
I'm going to add the CSS file in the
description box this main area.js file
CSS file in the description box you can
check it out and also you can add the
folder and just
improvise this project
coming back to our code
obsessors and then the
uh handle down
the color of the blue let's have blue
now
okay and the font size
to him
okay
and this is looks fine
see
yep
in the head let's work on the main part
after the students I'm gonna create
another Dev
last name
near area
okay this step let's add
a story by first take this story but we
are going to add these Wheels part which
shows you I am going to cover it in my
next videos
till now I'm going to cover these
shots or status
let's hope on this
again inside this main area
okay
thank you let's continue
again I'm going to create one the
classroom
that's right
story
yeah
nice
button
this part here
story
yeah
yeah like this so I'm going to add one
image here
to source of the image would be
fake
and the folder images
G
Ave me
three four
six four
Dot
filter
let's try this part here little
how it would be
three pixels
which would be 50.
brackets
then the water radius
they will be fine
okay
let's close this
and after that
what we will do is Select break
let's add the
SE five six
yeah
and after that I'll read
[Music]
let's save it first
let me declare or let's say do it in the
end okay
you will save our time also
so what we are going to do is we are
going to copy this part
from here let's copy this and let's
write
paste it one two three four
five
yes so let's
let's change the name of these
click
because
[Music]
flowers
shadow
it looks like
save it
in declare some errors
great neither is that because we have to
import these modules like
which we have the J like these modules
in the top here so you have to write all
of them in one go okay
so after these let's change the name of
these images
okay
see the names okay
yeah
seven
two
six
eight five five
nine two six seven
two six seven
and then left is three to seven
three two seven eight is not General
it's nine two seven one two
project g p and g
let's try to simulate but let's try it
PNG
technology
foreign
[Music]
this is your screen
let's create another day of class
name text
after this tiny lips
class
opposed
say this post I'm going to write
the net source
again inside the images folder
and ID
3464.wg
foreign
let's move forward
let me just copy and paste that
volunteer so you I'll explain you after
that
wait now I have edit all the code which
was left here
as you can see
after this image I am taken one input
text in this info it was a type of money
and the placeholder which will come
inside that was what's on your mind
number and like this we have closed this
line again we are calling some icons for
that these icons are like this
like the second the second and the
second
after that I have declared that in that
indicate the names of that part
like as you can see here
okay then
this is one image content
that I have
shown
I have declared one image or simply
learned inside the simple level
is the image link after that it's
uploaded and his cover image things that
are written on Facebook when you appear
to upload a picture or something after
that there is this div class of caption
inside that please comment like share
and things it comes into captioning
people write things like that and after
that it's the comment like shared in
that things button okay and after that
we'll come to the left side of this
speech here I have written contact in
all of the icons that magnify glass icon
that we see on Facebook page that we can
see here in the Facebook page you will
see that the contacts this room option
search and this name data only or these
are all your friends so I have to tell
you some of my engineer
and inside that I've declared these
things after that
it's completed and then we have exported
the file in the first case only so now
we'll save this file and already I have
added all the CSS file
all this uses is done here
you'll have the folder Link in the
description box you can just copy all
the things and enjoy
it's now add the
code
let's write
just
f a angle you'll find these
then you find everything like very
easily
Facebook image not done so let's
if it's not faced down then it will just
be like a light color then you can just
see it's wrong okay
angle down is done
throw some flag
with your friends
third
and thumbs up
to move your head
commence
that so it was a thumbs up
but it was she is here
yeah
everything is imported now
from
react
icons
slash FM okay now we have already
taken some from
MD and AI so again I'm going to write
import
it's not fetching okay
we can see the issue here no problem MD
and there was another name
from
yeah okay icons
yes
it's not coming where
spelling is true
everything is fine now
it's just uh this morning
image from
okay
react
icons
yeah
let's save it
and see for any issues
bus station for me
if it clear is not defined okay
maybe I have to clear one
okay
I was declared but forgot about it
okay it was
let's do it
that's somebody successfully now let's
see the output are you ready
so this is our page
isn't it looking amazing
right
these are the story by its name in the
and this is the picture that I have
uploaded you can like comment and share
it
you can write anything if you are
feeling anything in live video These are
the small things that I have shared with
you you can anytime improvise this
project
okay
now
let's close this coming back to our code
so
with this we have the end of this video
make sure to hit the like button
subscribe button and please
comment on this if you find any
difficulties just comment it down and
I'll reach you thank you so much guys
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here